Most of us eat a diet which is based on potatoes, wheat, rice and sweet things.
Whilst starch and sugar may look very different,...
...they're actually digested by the body in a similar way.
They both turn into glucose in the bloodstream, which is known as blood sugar,...
...and it's just cheap, fast energy for the body.
Some of these foods turn into glucose faster than others...
...but ultimately they all turn into blood sugar.
Now the problem with blood sugar is that if we don't use it relatively quickly,...
...it becomes toxic.
So the body has developed a very effective way...
...to remove excess blood sugar from the bloodstream.
It has a faithful dog called Insulin to fetch it.
Insulin retrieves the excess, unused blood sugar in the bloodstream...
...and then stores a little as glycogen in our muscles and liver,...
...but stores most of it as fat in our bodies, mostly around our tummies.
Now, as long as we keep eating starch and sugar,...
...Insulin will keep retrieving unused blood sugar and store it as fat as fast as it can.
And we get fatter and fatter and, well, fatter.
Poor old Insulin.
He's a very tired dog.
If we keep eating starch and sugar and, poor old us, we'll have a large store of fat...
...which is actually just unused blood sugar from eating starch and sugar.
So, hopefully you can now see how foods that don't actually look like fat...
...can become fat in our bodies.